[موسيقى]
غالبيه ودول باعت قطاع الاتصالات
للمقاولين لانها رات فيه قابليه للربح
وبالتالي راينا الحكومات محكومه بمشاريع
ورؤى شركات الاتصالات التي لا تملكها من
اجل ضمان توفير الانترنت لمواطنيها
والانها نحن في وضع النرى فيه دوله واحده
هي التي تشرف على عمليه استخدام الانترنت
لان كل شركات التكنولوجيا تنتمي لهذه
الدوله ما جعل البعد السياسي اهم من مفهوم
المراقبه
[موسيقى]
نعم مثال ذلك الحكومه الهنديه فقد اقتنعت
بان هذا الامر يمثل مشكلا لذلك بدات تطلب
وراء الخبراء ومنهم انا للنظر في كيفيه
تغيير البرامج الكبرى القائمه فيما يتعلق
هذه هي المره الاولى التي تعلن فيها حكومه
انها على وعي بالمشكل وتطلب وراء الخبراء
والناس بما يجعلها تضفي على صناعه
الكابلات بعدا سياسيا عبر اعتمادها على
الذات فيما يتعلق بالانترنت
[موسيقى]